you wrote the book how to spend 75
billion dollars to make the world a
better place so on can we just list some
of the things if I if if you got 75
billion dollars what how do you spend
them all right so there's some
incredibly good and very very well
documented things that you could spend
money on so we have two big infectious
diseases that almost nobody think about
uh because we only think about you know
covet uh but tuberculosis used to be the
world's biggest infectious disease
killer uh it still kills about one and a
half million uh people every year the
reason why we don't you know really
worry about it is because we fixed it a
hundred years ago we know how to fix it
it's just you know it's just basically
getting medication to people it's also
about getting them to take it while when
they're sort of been cured because you
need to take it for four to six months
and that's actually hard to do so you
also need to incentivize that in some
kind of way it turns out it's incredibly
cheap to basically save almost all of
the 1.5 million people these are people
that die in the prime of their lives
they're typically parents so you would
also have a lot of knock-on effects and
basically we find for a couple billion
dollars you could save the value vast
number of these not all of them but you
could save the vast number of them it
will also improve you know outcomes in
all kinds of other ways likewise with
malaria another it has some somewhat
better uh PR it's funny to think of
malaria as PR and tuberculosis 9 they
need to improve their PR department
those mosquitoes are the good PR but by
far the biggest infectious disease uh
that got good PR if you will was HIV
right yes because and that and and I'm
not trying to compare it and say oh it's
worse or better to have HIV than to
tuberculosis or anything but I'm simply
saying we are under funding because it
doesn't really get the public
attention we just yeah we don't spending
money on that as uh in terms of benefit
a much bigger impact so every dollar you
spend on TB will probably do about 43
dollars worth of good so it'll do an
amazing amount of good basically because
it'll save lives they'll make sure
parents stay with their kids and be more
productive active in their communities
and they'll you know have a lot of
knock-on effects and it's incredibly
cheap to do same thing with malaria it's
mostly mosquito Nets that we need to get
out and you're saying just the contrast
with climate change the dollar you spend
on no not climate change but decreasing
emissions
does not have does not come close to the
43 dollar benefit no nobody nobody would
ever argue that so very very
enthusiastic climate Advocates would
probably say it'll do two or three
dollars worth of good for every dollar
so you know it's still worthwhile to do
that's what they would say I would argue
and I think a lot of the evidence seems
to side that way that a lot of the
things that we're doing deliver actually
lessen it all or back but but it's
certainly not nearly the same kind of
place but there's many many other things
and you know just if if you'll allow me
yes please I love this but uh yeah there
are lots of other things for instance uh
e-procurement so uh you know it's
incredibly boring so most developing
countries well actually most governments
spend most of their money on procurement
is typically incredibly corrupt so we
did this project for Bangladesh uh where
can you explain procurement yes so
that's governments buying stuff uh so a
large part of the government revenue is
spent on buying anywhere anything from
you know Post-it notes to roads and
obviously you know roads are much much
more expensive is mostly infrastructure
stuff hugely corrupt uh for instance in
Bangladesh
um it would already have been decided
among the ruling Elite in that local
area who's going to get this uh so
they'll have this bidding competition
where you have to hand in an envelope a
seal envelope with your bid on it but
you put a goon outside the office so you
literally physically can't get in with
your uh with your bid
now what we found and this is you know
I'm not I'm not claiming any sort of
ownership to this a lot of smart people
have done this way before we're just
simply proving that is a good idea
um it turns out that if you put this on
eBay essentially so if you do an
e-procurement system where bidders can
come in suddenly it becomes harder to
put up the Goon you can still do it but
it's harder to do it it also means you
get bits from all over Bangladesh and
and in general uh you'll get bits from
all over actually turns out you get
better quality but most important is you
get it much cheaper so basically you can
simply save money so we we did a scaled
experiment in Bangladesh where we had
about four percent go to uh to be uh
e-procurement and you could compare what
it would have cost and then what it did
cost and the average reduction was as I
remember it's seven percent and the
Finance Minister loved it you know
because that basically gives him a lot
more money or you know you can buy more
stuff at the same cost no digital
corruption
so it's it's basically you get rid of
some corruption there'll still be
corruption but less corruption Ukraine
has actually been big on this they I
have talked to them I talked to the
digital transformation Minister it's
kind of incredible I mean this is before
the war but still working uh it's like
the entirety of the government is in an
app and that one of the big effects
is the reduction of corruption and not
like from uh this was a politician say
to say we've reduced we've taken these
action through this court no literally
is just much more difficult to be
corrupt yeah the incentives aren't quite
there and they there's friction for
corruption yeah oh yeah yeah so
basically uh you can spend a little bit
of money and you can make a huge benefit
there's still about 70 countries that
haven't gone e-procurement so obviously
they should do that food for small kids
another thing so you know uh basically
you know it's morally wrong that people
are starving uh but it also turns out
that it's a really really dumb thing not
to get kids good food because if you get
them good food their brains develop more
so that when they get into school they
learn more and so when they come out in
adult lives they're much more productive
so we can actually make every kid in
especially in developing countries much
more productive by making sure they get
good food so getting good food is not
cost free so it probably cost about a
hundred dollars uh both in and you you
need some uh directed advertisement you
need to make sure that you actually get
some of the food out there that you help
the families and you also make sure you
don't just give it to everyone because
then it becomes a lot more expensive if
you do that right it costs about a
hundred dollars per kid but per kid or
for two years so it's for their first
two years of life
um and if you do that
you then get a benefit in that they
become smarter and go longer to school
and they actually learn more and become
more productive of forty five hundred
dollars remember this is far out into
the future so the this is discounted the
benefit is actually much higher and this
is one of the things that we also have a
conversation about in in climate change
because all and when you talk about
climate change cost and benefits all the
costs are now and all the benefits are
in the future but it's just like that in
education you know all the costs are now
all the benefits are far into the future
and if you try to do that right and
that's a whole other conversation that
we could have uh then it turns out that
for every dollar spent you do 45 dollars
worth of good again remember about a a
third of all kids that go to school
right now just don't learn pretty much
anything yeah and if we could make them
more productive in the school system we
have another proposal and how to do that
in the in the school system but you know
by just simply making sure that they're
that they're smarter when they get into
School we've been focusing so much on
making the education system better which
is really hard but it's actually really
easy to make the kids smarter then when
you say the education system is not
working well that's we're talking about
not the American education system we're
talking about globally yes we're talking
about globally you know so about a third
of the teachers in developing countries
have a hard time passing the tests of
the things they have to teach their
students right and and you know all
these students have lots of other issues
you know there's there they need to do
farm work they they need uh yeah uh they
they're constantly considering should I
just go out and start working instead uh
you know there's there's constant
disruption there's a lot of teachers
that don't show up and India you know
you have uh you have this absurd
situation where all the teachers are
basically paid and hired for eternity
for the rest of their lives and so not
surprisingly a lot of them decide not to
show up so now they've hired assistant
teachers that basically have taken over
so they're paying you know for I think
it's seven million teachers that I'm not
saying they're not all all not working
but a lot of them are not working as
much as they should and we now hired
another seven million teachers that have
it will eventually you know stop working
as well they're they're working much
better right now because they're you
know they're they're not on on permanent
contracts but eventually they'll get
empowerment contracts and then you have
the same problem again there's lots of
these issues and you know it's just
simply about saying we can't fix all
problems but there are some problems
that are incredibly easy to solve and
there are some that are incredibly hard
to solve why don't we start with solving
the easy and effective ones and this of
course Bears on that whole conversation
on climate change because in some ways
you know that's that's also Andy's point
of saying look if you want to save
people from from the impacts of
hurricanes let's fix this simple easy
things about vulnerability first whereas
we have somehow latched on to this let's
fix the hardest thing to do which is to
get everyone to stop using fossil fuels
which is basically what's Driven the
last 200 years of development that's
going to be that's a tall order no
matter how you look at it there's some
really cool elements that you guys just
brought up would you mention that word
moral before I wasn't alleged on it
because it relates to
these time scales that really are
immeasurable if you know it's going to
take decades to confirm the benefit of
some investment now
that implies you're doing the investment
with some moral imperative not because
you can do a spreadsheet and come up
with a number
and that that process letting go of the
need
for kind of a mechanistic cost benefit
approach thinking about kids education
in poor countries or several things
we've talked about seems to be really
important and it's very hard for all of
us to do philanthropists suck at it I've
worked at National Geographic Society
for a year building some new programs
when they got a big infusion money they
have a whole department that's called M
and E it's measurement and evaluation
which is if you don't prove it it goes
away I mentioned Spotify earlier Spotify
killing a climate podcast because that
podcast didn't measure measure out for
their
impact you know what they want to do and
um if we're always making the judgments
based on strict cost benefit we're going
to miss
larger realities another thing is
another a really exciting example of
what you're talking about
in terms of in Ukraine with the trust
and lack of less corruption and stuff
was in India
for all of his issues Modi um
recognized that middle class people in
India Cook on LPG propane or on piped
gas natural gas if they're in cities
much cleaner much healthier
in so many ways and actually compared to
like chopping down trees and cook
cooking on wood it's actually better for
the climate even though it's a fossil
fuel
so he
he and others those American scientist
Kirk Smith who worked this all out
um if you find a way you had to tr they
were getting a subsidy they had they had
that energy subsidies you were talking
about many poor countries subsidized
energy just to stay in office you know
to make something cheap that everyone
wants
um but they wanted to shift the subsidy
away from the middle class to the poor
poor people who were cooking on firewood
and dying Young from pneumonia
and what the the critical Factor was
India's digital currency India went to a
digital economy
very poor families there now if you have
a phone you basically that's your bank
and you could make the case to the
public that we're we're going to be
starting to shift your
LPG your propane subsidy to poor people
but we know they're poor
we know they're not just going to be
using it behind their restaurant which
was you know the when it was a general
subsidy people were hoarding the LPG and
and the system has worked they've
shifted a lot of
capacity to cook on a clean blue flame
that turns off and on in homes that
previously where the woman would spend
hours collecting firewood
Smokey fire cooking clean the pots and
start all over again but it's all built
on trust all built on the digital
economy that and the same thing in
Nairobi so that excites me every day you
know with all the doomism
I just hope people can literally
take a breath
look for these examples
um that show the potential when you have
a trustworthy system when you have a
clear path to making lives better
and then knowing you know that kid
having electric light as opposed to a
kerosene lamp we don't know how much
that's going to improve his homework
and lead to a better outcome but we know
from history that sometimes it does van
ki-moon former Secretary General so the
most powerful story I ever heard from a
U.N Secretary General was like 2012 when
they were rolling out
this sustainable energy for all
initiative which is not just climate
it's just like getting people energy
they need to
survive and thrive he's he was growing
up in post-war Korea
everyone's poor everything was broken
destroyed
sadly like so much of you many parts of
Ukraine and he would do his homework by
kerosene lamp
he said when he was studying for his
finals his mom would give him a candle
because it was a brighter flame you know
better grades maybe and he became
Secretary General